نشر المراسل العسكري في موقع ولا
الاسرائيلي انتقادات لاذعه وجهها عدد من
الجنود في قواه الاحتياط الى جزء من
القياده العسكريه واشك الجنود من ان القده
لا يكترثون لهم في الميدان ولا لسير
العمليات والنواقص التي تعاني منها القوات
على مستوى الذخيره وعدد المقاتلين واكدوا
ان الاستخبارات العسكريه لا علاقه لها بما
يحدث على ارض الواقع كما نقل المراسل عن
مجموعه من العسكريين الذين خرجوا من غزه
قولهم انهم سئموا رؤيه مسؤولين كبار في
قياده اركان الجيش يقومون بجولات تفقديه
وكانهم يحاربون الى جانب الجنود لكنهم في
الواقع تفوح منهم رائحه العطور ويلتقطون
الصور فحسب دون الالتفات لاحتياجات الجنود
وسؤالهم عن اوضاعهم في الميدان واعرب
الجنود والضباط عن حاله احباط لا سما
وانهم يشعرون بان سلاح الجو ما عاد يقدم
لهم اسنادا جويا خلال الاسابيع الاخيره
وان اهدافه باتت محدوده وقالوا انه يبدو
كما لو انه اصبح من الصعب تحديد الاهداف
وازاله التهديدات وانه لا يجري تحديث
الخطط العسكريه وفقا للمستجدات وقل جهوزيه
فرقه غزه للمناوره
البريه